In this tutorial, we'll be
talking about how to run the
PHP samples for a
YouTube V3 API.
For this to work, you'll need
a local installation
of Apache and PHP.
I'm running this demo on OSX,
which ships with a version of
Apache with PHP.
To enable PHP, I just
have to make a few
configuration changes.
The first thing you want to
do is verify that our PHP
installation is working
correctly.
You can skip this if you know
that it is working correctly.
I'm going to go ahead and
create a new PHP file.
I'm going to edit it.
Now I'm going to go ahead and
browse to this PHP file.
And I can see that
it's working.
So let's go ahead and
download the API
client library for PHP.
We can find this at
code.google.com/
p/google-API-PHP-client.
We'll click on Download
the Latest Release.
While we're doing that, we
also want to download the
YouTube API samples.
We can find these at
code.google.com/
p/youtube-api-samples.
Click on the download
link, and we'll
download the samples.
Once these have downloaded,
we should unpack them.
Let's now copy the files into
a directory that we'll be
running PHP files off of.
We'll also want to copy
the PHP samples over.
Now, let's give it the
proper permissions.
I'm recursively giving
it 7, 5, 5.
Now let's make the search
sample work.
The first thing we'll need
to do is call set
include path on our code.
We'll want to include the Google
API client library.
We'll also need to set
the developer key.
We can find this from the
Google API console,
code.google.com/APIs/console.
If you browse there, and you
don't see this page, you'll
want to watch a video about how
to create and register a
YouTube API key.
Scroll down to Simple
API Access.
Let's copy the key.
And let's paste it over
the place holder.
Let's save the file and browse
through this search sample.
We should see this page.
And when we click Search, we'll
see the search results.
The next sample we'll try to
get running will be the My
Upload sample.
So let's go ahead and open that
up in our text editor.
The sample demonstrates how to
use the three legged OAuth 2.0
flow to authorize your script
to run on behalf of user.
We'll need to copy over
set include path.
We'll also need to
set the client ID
and the client secret.
Again, we can find these in
the Google API console.
Now let's go ahead
and run our code.
Note that this first run
will not work yet.
We'll be asked to authorize, and
we'll see an error page.
It's because we need to
register this URI as a
redirect URI in the
API console.
So let's go ahead and copy it,
go back to the API console,
click on Edit settings.
We'll paste it into the
authorized redirect URI's box.
Let's click update.
Now let's click back and try
to run our sample again.
And run the code again.
You'll see that the code
is now requesting
that I allow access.
I'll click Allow.
The script is now running.
So that's what you need to run
the sample codes for Search
and My Uploads in PHP.